mit einmischung in den syrischen
eigentlich gerade das beschaffungsamt
wird doch nicht nachsagen doch
thema aufrüstung oder wie wir nicht
diplomaten
in deutschland schon viel früher waffen
noch zum thema nato sagen wollte haben
gehen oder stehen bleiben
das war jetzt eine absichtserklärung ein
europäischen oder nato verbund oben
weil es mehr leute von der botschaft
eigentlich für mindestens 1000 politik
wir haben alles getan und es gibt krieg
depots und waffensysteme in den
beim finanzministerium nachgeholfen 1
einen schritt auf sie zu also ich sage
unreflektierten willenlose
konflikt hätten tschetschenien wir haben
wir in bildung die wir in kultur den
aktuellen koalitionsvertrag als
einfach nicht sicher sind und plötzlich
sagen ausrüstung über das thema sprechen
irgendwie kritik steht und auf der
ebenso viel gefährlicher und anders als
das wäre ja der fall wenn das
steht
hätten die frauen sollen zum beispiel an
sander die coverband weiter wir waren da
plan den die regierung vorgelegter das
zu sehen das militär aufzustocken ich
kompromissvorschläge ihr euch überlegt
auch irgendwie angehen möchte also wir
städtepartnerschaften investieren für
befehlsempfänger ganz im gegenteil da
also ich würd sagen das ist die klare
wir deutsche uns auch immer auf die usa
wir erleben eine zeitenwende das waren
museum.de nette seite kam mal gucken
so viele konflikte gab bei dem wir
sind da relativ selten frauen beteiligt
feministische außenpolitik festgehalten
streitkräften dann war der fall des
die in die budgets müssen weiter in
quasi auch kosten und effizienz sparend
ok paul ist der einzige der stehen
die ukraine um die
rückt der krieg hier ein wenig näher und
sondervermögen aus dem haushalt kommt
habe das grüne feld ihr könnt gerne
hat nichts mit hinterzimmer politik zu
verteidigungsfähigkeit zu erhöhen und so
antwort darauf dass er zur diplomatie
müssen eine andere art von außenpolitik
und zwei soldaten wander und nach 1 jk
gesagt haben ach ja und es geht es
den frieden langfristig besser
diskussion hat sehr gut gezeigt dass ja
anderen seite ist ja schon der punkt
verlassen um so das eigentlich zu tun
februar 2022 gezeigt hat dass frieden
transparente daten 2021 wurden
würde dann würde ich zustimmen also zb
hat nämlich anzuerkennen dass nicht alle
anfangen also wir sind klar dafür dass
bildung und gesundheit fließen das ist
glaube dass es auf jeden fall aus dem
gibt sich auch eine aufgabe des
geblieben ist warum beschränken heißt ja
eisernen vorhangs und der glaube war der
ich finde das ist grundsätzlich erstmal
angelegtes als jetzt mehr waffen zu
die wahrscheinlichkeit eines krieges zu
afghanistan und syrien war ich glaube du
tun das ist eine erklärung die jetzt ja
gerade sagt daniel warum bist du so
die worte von bundeskanzler olaf scholz
dass man das vergleichen muss mit
klar 100 milliarden das ist sehr viel
irgendwie nichts an und weggeschaut und
es wird etwas unbequemer und dieses
historischen verantwortung heraus
rechtsextremismus problem in der
irgendwie zu investieren was sagt ihr zu
langfristig schaffen ich habe ich gesagt
sehr schade und ich glaube das ist
gar keine frage es soll ja auch nicht
dass man trotzdem ziemlich großen anteil
kaufen fragt doch mal deine freundin der
großen schritt zurückgegangen
verringern und deshalb müssen wir
haben wir alle über die situation
ich bin total froh dass vermisste
freiheit und demokratie keine
ausgegeben 46 93 milliarden euro für die
jedes jegliche diplomatie ausgeschöpft
was wir auch hätten tun können und
anderen budgets und mit den budgets
jetzt plötzlich sollen wir sozusagen so
deutschland ein anderes verhältnis zum
nach dem russischen einmarsch in die
menschen gleichen zugang zu macht
wir sollten erst aufrüsten und dann
bist ein schritt nach hinten gegangen
geld wir müssen über das geld sprechen
aus diesen töpfen genommen werden
bundeswehr über das bild vielleicht auch
groß diskutiert würde ich mein bestehen
von sie militärisch gibt oder
unbedingt sicherstellen dass uns so ein
ewige friede bericht aus und wir haben
ukraine aber sie erfolgt ob sie jetzt
selbstverständlichkeit sind und dass wir
wichtig dass man die sicherheit von
militär hat also und gleichzeitig haben
außenpolitik im koalitionsvertrag stand
dem kompromissvorschlag geht er einen
gesprochen und diese band aus kiew die
ich halte es für problematisch
dieses statement aufrüstung kann ja auch
anderer ministerien weil natürlich wir
unsere minister außenpolitik kommen will
ukraine und wenn in diesen tagen von
mal platz gibt es nicht auch in der
möglichkeiten und ressourcen haben und
deswegen bin ich da hat ein stück
frauen und kindern mit denkt denn ich
reagieren das halte ich für ich habe es
aber vor allem ist die frage die wir uns
gerade hier und überziehen genau das ist
sollen hätten wir uns richtig
sein muss bis es zu einer aufrüstung
fand ich extrem wichtig ich finde wir
eingespart und zwar massiv eingespart
fehler nicht noch einmal passiert und
schritt auf die gelbe seite zu also erst
das geld in die schulen investieren
bundeswehr ist eine steigerung von 13
ich denke noch über dieses abschreckungs
polizei wir wollen nicht die polizei
vorgegangen war ein schritt vorgegangen
ich das habe ich nicht gesagt soll ich
einer zeitenwende die rede ist dann ist
wir sicherlich eine große verantwortung
zeigt ja dass es kein einsatz immer
glaube aber ist es kein widerspruch es
hier eigentlich stellen müssen was
jungen leute haben gesagt wir fühlen uns
zusagen putin würde auf die eine
genau von hier weil du grundsätzlich
seit 30 jahren
nicht diese unterschied machen können
ausgerüstet und hätten wir eigentlich
abschaffen ja aber darüber reden wir ja
für falsch tatsächlich und ich hatte ein
müssen auch über feministische
dass uns das vor massive neue konflikt
hab gesagt wir müssen beides tun weil
deshalb müssen wir die lehren ziehen aus
einmal für dich das ein richtig guter
in vielen anderen aspekten von
prozent im vergleich zum jahr 2020 plus
kommt allerdings muss die abschreckung
würden oder in ihrer verteidigung eine
einfach weil ich sehe dass das ein thema
auf kosten der streitkräfte auf kosten
für internationalen frieden und
als europäer und europäerinnen wir
szenario nach was du von als notwendig
damit oft auch ein radikaler
politik ist sondern eben ein ein angebot
wollen wir überhaupt was wollen wir
zwischen das eine ist investitionen
verteidigungspolitik zum beispiel reden
die rolle übernommen und die
bisschen bigott und doppel moralisch
ist ja auch im sinne von zwei spielern
wir müssen auf der einen seite klar
grundsätzlich kommt us-vorschlag am ende
verteidigung gesehen werden und ich
dieser neuen situation ehrlich warum
zum beispiel gar nicht mehr ich muss
sicherheit also ich bin grundsätzlich
treiber stellt stefan kannst du
sicherheitspolitisch für eine rolle
in einer situation gelebt haben die so
wollen zu euch wir hören eure musik wir
vermischung von außenpolitischen in
der vorgegeben sein damit wir das
frieden und das andere ist investitionen
das könnte man auch mal sehr sinnvoll
richtungswechsel in der deutschen außen-
machen wir als deutsche bundesregierung
dass man das jetzt erst macht barbara
empfunden hast und ich habe die zahl
auch dazu sagen als jüdin und
ist was wichtig ist und was auch weiter
ein plan der vorgelegt wird den wir
verantwortung übernommen die meiner
dagegen dass weil ich deswegen hier
100 milliarden jetzt sondervermögen die
glaube dass dieser punkt einfach sehr
der bundeswehr und das fällt uns jetzt
nicht abgeneigt zu sagen wir brauchen
politischen fragen können
einnehmen weltweit aber was wollen wir
bist du ein schritt nach hinten gegangen
von frauen von kindern dass eine gewisse
tun darf er nicht nur außenpolitik
des tages habe ich das gefühl dass ihr
enkeltochter von zwei
wie als deutschland wir können uns da
dann ihr seid auch schritt
in die küche zu hause
verstehen dass in der gesellschaft es
thematisiert werden muss ich glaube aber
meinung nach auch deutschland übernehmen
gegenüber dazu zwingen müssen sich für
und sicherheitspolitik gemeint mit hilfe
wichtig ist einfach nicht genug
wollen es wir wollen sie sagen holt uns
recherchiert im vorfeld dieses gespräch
ich glaube weil diese rosarote brille
ich glaube toten reagiert momentan auf
jetzt alle hier gemeinschaftlich
in irgendeiner weise nicht nur gefunden
angetreten bin heute und das wird glaube
nicht nochmal wiederkommen wird den
auf die füße und wir müssen jetzt etwas
zurückgegangen was sagt ihr denn so
betreffende feministische
auch konkret von der bundeswehr was für
holocaust-überlebenden sehe ich deshalb
muss
nicht ernsthaft mit dem
vermischen aussenpolitik und wir möchten
also um dieses bild aufzugreifen weil
trotzdem dass das thema sondervermögen
thematisiert wird woher weißt du dass
leute empfinden als hätte da ein
diskutiert wir sind nur nicht der
dass die nato schon das 20 fache dessen
entwicklungspolitik und so stimmte
verteidigungsfähigkeit da ist und
eine bundeswehr die
ich auch stehen ihr könnt euch jetzt ein
paul daniel ihr seid ein schritt auf sie
worden im schuhkarton innenministerium
eines sondervermögens in höhe von 100
kompromissvorschlag bereits seit das
gar keine diplomatie und das liegt auch
dazu es war sozusagen die konfrontation
den diplomatischen weg zu entscheiden
vergangenen jahren hat man auf die
nelly die gesagt hat okay das ist mir
aufgaben soll sie übernehmen welche
steigst du aber dieses quasi den
bundestag also nicht verwechseln daniel
dass unterfüttern zum beispiel in der
aufholen was wir in den letzten
kompromissvorschlag überlegen ihr könnt
es auch als so wichtig an die
berlin aktuell gefährdet ist
die wir uns alle gerne wünschen würden
austausch bevor diese entscheidung
ausgibt was russland ausgibt und das ist
die jetzt plötzlich auftauchen plus wenn
wir natürlich irgendwie um in frieden zu
für eine aufrüstung oder eben neue
wenn eine massive sicherheitsgefährdung
einsatz bereit ist die frage ist aber
das ist der kompromissvorschlag von
fähigkeiten der bundeswehr sehr gern
alles ein bisschen rosarote brille ja
deshalb ich glaube man sollte es nicht
nicht und das ist glaube ich eine
einander aufbrechen dann wäre der fall
milliarden euro und einer generellen
zugegangen warum ja ich finde kommentar
euch ein kompromissvorschlag überlegen
du bist ein schritt franziska zugegangen
an uns weil wir doppelte zeichen aus
jahrzehnten sträflich vernachlässigt
war schon da und die kriegerischen lande
gesellschaft damit ins boot zu nehmen
widerspruch sehen sondern quasi im
nicht real ist bin ich einen schritt
entwicklungspolitik und so weiter und
ich sage es mal so eine bundeswehr eine
grünfeld an euch ihr könnt euch jetzt
diskussion die wir wahrscheinlich noch
zurückgegriffen und verwechselte glaube
ausrüstung hier gar kein paradox gibt
wenn wir jetzt aus einer misslichen geld
man das war prozent ziel erfüllt wären
stattfand ein krieg dass die bundeswehr
getroffen wurde gefehlt dass die
investieren denn diplomatie investieren
aufstockung des verteidigungshaushalts
und zu sagen wir müssten alle einer
sofort in allen bereichen aber
ich bin sehr gespannt was ihr euch
zurückgegangen weil wir die aufrüstung
senden wir üben uns einerseits um eine
sieht man doch dass die abschreckung
viele viele weitere male führen müssen
ich würde vielleicht gerne anknüpfen an
zum waschen da und diese konnten diese
gesamtkonstrukt und ich glaube wenn man
wofür und vor allen dingen dass die
warum ich muss einen schritt nach vorne
haben und müssen die bundeswehr
gerne positionieren und einen schritt
das also 67 milliarden jährlich plus
sehr gut dass ich die ganze zeit krieg
nicht funktioniert also ich finde das
wegnehmen würden oder so und das dann in
gesellschaft vielleicht nicht genug mit
müssen den entwicklungszusammenarbeit
starke bundeswehr es für mich in der
gleichzeitig müssen wir eben
überlegt
dem punkt zu sagen es hat ja nicht
soll die bundeswehr soll deutschland
ausrüsten und deswegen stehen wir auf
dann ich würde gerne dich ansprechen du
investieren müssen und die budgets sind
brauchen um überhaupt eine diplomatische
herrscht irgendwo auf der welt und dass
frage in welcher priorität sprechen wir
die bundeswehr stecken würden das ist ja
auf sie zugehen zurückgehen stehen
sich bereit machen solche und eben da
bundeswehr dienen oder dem land dienen
tun wenn du sagst die gesellschaft muss
veränderung hier in deutschland dass wir
ist eine logik die sich mir einfach
gleichzeitig verteidigungs fähig sein
das tut dann tut man der sicherheit von
einbezogen wurde in diese 100 milliarden
und auch breit gesellschaftlich und das
sohn hat mich an insgesamt 167
bisschen mit einem besseren thw und der
diese zerrissenheit des landes ist da
herzlich willkommen bei 310 fragen schön
wir das jetzt einfach dadurch dass
153 milliarden die wir die wir bereits
funktioniert und deswegen müssen wir
bleiben paul denken du willst auf der
warst zehn jahre lang soldat bei der
extra nicht der fall deshalb dieses
nicht erschließt franziska warum ist es
sagen wir haben jetzt eine feministische
wehrhafter werden was für die einen eine
indem wir uns heute in deutschland zu
was machen wir jetzt paul wie willst du
auch aufrüsten solche militärisch
allen den größten gefallen ich würde mir
darüber debattieren über den krieg und
lösung finden zu können ich glaube nur
krankenversicherung abschließen und will
in dem haushalt
milliarden euro das scheint mir nicht so
geografisch näher ist als mehr als unser
jetzt was anderes machen wir haben es
und ich finde das ist etwas worüber wir
euro und in diesen radikalen
sondervermögen barbara du beschäftigt
bundeswehr
hat uns glaube ich diese folge 13 tragen
darüber also wir haben zum beispiel aus
außenpolitik oder feministisch ihre
dass ihr alle da seid ich freue mich
kamera noch gesehen werden du bist
deshalb kann ich quasi wieder vor noch
ich frage die frage ist die
du bist aber trotzdem auf derselben
hause fühlen und ich sehe das gar nicht
sprechen sollte dass es dem kran ein
nicht abschreckung genug naja weil die
wenig zu sein wenn man vergleicht wie
sie aber absolut nicht in anspruch
richtungswechsel
über das was jetzt an maßnahmen kommt
hatten warum hat dieses geld nicht
problem betrachten
2022 gerade kleiner angesetzt als im
wenn man militärisch abschrecken kann
sehr auf die diskussion und starrte
der historischen verantwortung heraus ja
und sehr sehr gut gezeigt wenn euch
seite des feldes und gegen eine
ich beruflich unter anderem mit
jemandem wie putin diplomatisch entgegen
wünschen dass auch putin an eine
eigentlich schon jetzt ganz
tatsächlich nie probiert also wir sind
zurück gehen ich hätte nicht gedacht
land das was von all dem gezogen wird
viele andere ministerien bekommen haben
ukraine nicht genug
gereicht es hat nicht gereicht um den
außenpolitik als wir die früher mal
ich glaube der jetzigen situation ist
direkt mit der konflikt frage mit der
nehmen und wenn wir das nicht haben dann
das könnte das system kann man zur
kommunikation zwischen traum und ich
kann man sich am tisch setzen und kann
diese 13 fragen folge gefallen wenn sie
aber genau das hat olaf scholz ja nicht
dass wir uns auch mehr hätten einigen
als streitkräfte in erster linie aber
aufrüstung warum ich habe in afghanistan
feministischer außenpolitik für die sich
jahr davor und das kann halt nicht sein
feministische außenpolitik glaubt ich
ganz klar gesagt es gibt ein privat
zukunft und den schutz der demokratie
alles offizielle quellen trends
ersten frage von 13 fragen sollte
ja eher nicht auch jetzt in der
finde sichert ihm auch ein schwieriges
gehen oder was wäre denn was wäre deinen
man den partner sagen du hast gar keine
gehabt haben auf der anderen seite
standard stand zu haben der jetzt
ist es meiner meinung nach einfach
stunde nichts aber was ist denn dann die
euch bereichert hat dann freuen wir uns
verteidigungsfähigkeit angriffskrieg von
führung gefragt nur diese führung ist
verhältnis zu das ist normal zur
getan und nicht zugelassen es wurden
ja auch wurde auch schon genannt
brennglas deutlich gemacht dass die
primates zivilen also quasi immer hat
glaube dann wären wir ein bisschen näher
können aber gleichzeitig muss sagen ich
wirklich als gesamtgesellschaftliches
situation
wort des echten gekämpft aber grill
ist bedeutet für die anderen dass wir
ministerium die
okay also ihr seid alle politisch stehen
fahrlässig was uns auch mal ganz kurz
andere wahl als jetzt uns hier mit der
vorschlag was sollen wir anders machen
annalena baerbock unter anderem stark
machen wir aber verteidigungspolitisch
sehr wenn ihr uns ein abo dallas das
notwendig wäre unglaubwürdig einen
einordnung das sondervermögen ist gerade
und auch im kosovo gesehen dass
2021 bildung wissenschaft forschung 28
fakten geschaffen es wurden 100
konsequenz also das genau meinst du
deutschland militärisch aufrüsten wenn
jeden fall spürbar situation ich bin mit
damit kann man das möglich rechtfertigen
fand es interessant
streitkräfte einen anderen auftrag haben
russland ausreichend abzuschrecken und
also zivile maßnahmen am vorrang
an dem kompromiss oder eine lösung zum
ich glaube nach wie vor dass es in
konstrukt und deswegen habe ich auch
auf dieses konkretes szenario darauf mal
den glauben über bord werfen dass wir in
und man muss beides immer zusammen
macht kannst du mal kurz erklären weil
dazu geeignet dass es nicht passiert
das was uns im westen in der nato in der
geblieben ganz hinten ihr seid alle ein
diplomatie ein kompromiss finden zu
ich fand es total cool also gegenüber zu
damit das heißt wir hätten von anfang an
könnt ihr hier machen hier oben gibt es
diesen menschen immer noch in kontakt
aufrüstung nicht dazu führt dass es
weil wir die ukraine zu sehr alleine
ihr sagt ja auf jeden fall wir müssen
barbara vorhin zugestimmt weil wir
milliarden euro in den raum gestellt das
russland an opposition gibt das
werden jetzt viele argumente von beiden
europa gar keine bundeswehr brauchen
gegner und das ist ja die russische
gemacht haben die eben massiv setzt auf
denken verteidigungspolitisch machen wir
einen kernauftrag und der heißt es so
und ich habe mich auch im vorfeld dieses
gucken stefan du du bist der soldaten
früher militärisch aufrüsten müssen um
schritt zurück gegangen warum also dem
weil das sondervermögen sind de facto
das ist glaube ich ein begriff den hat
müssen uns dass wir müssen es neu denken
ein weiteres video von 13 fragen und
lassen und das gelingt nur mit einer
uns besser verteidigen können dann geht
intellektuelle künstler und so weiter
gelassen haben das würde ich schon so
frieden ich glaube dass bisschen
föderation seit dem 24 2 ganz offenbar
zumindest nicht zur kriegsführung wie
stehen die argumente auszutauschen und
man in letzter zeit sehr sehr oft und
ist ein ganz klares zeichen in richtung
gesprächs mit diesen menschen
seiten gehört und wenn ihr jetzt sagt es
friedlicher wird ich kam 2005 in einem
genauso weiter wie eh und je der
schulden die wir aufnehmen die aber dazu
koalitionsvertrag feministische
europäischen union zusammen hält vor
schön im grundgesetz der bund stellt
gesundheit 16 9 5 milliarden
krad aber toxische männlichkeit
er jetzt bitter das grüne feld und wenn
sagen die ukraine hat immer wieder
hier unten ein weiteres video zum thema
da souverän zu sein oder wie genau kann
abschreckung ich würde sehr sehr gerne
unrealistisch genau deswegen das noch
innen gibt die unterdrückt werden die
dominanz auf eben die staatliche
wir müssen gucken wie investieren wir
hat einen guten einblick in den zustand
der ambitionen die deutschland in der
sehr viel was ist das überhaupt
wollen wir also in der zukunft frieden
auseinandergesetzt und das leid dort ist
gibt einen kompromissvorschlag der jetzt
gesprochen das klingt ziemlich super
außenpolitik verschrieben wir haben
zu versuchen sich anzunähern ich glaube
ihr sagt nein auf gar keinen fall dann
streitkräfte zur verteidigung auf und
abzuschrecken davor uns anzugreifen und
feministische außenpolitik und auch
richtig rein und genau deswegen ist ja
gesagt achtung ein krieg steht bevor wir
toxisch ich gesagt das heißt ich habe
der bundeswehr der inspektor des
wohnungswesen städtebau 2,27 wir ja
führen dass kein anderes ressort jetzt
unbedingt genannt werden muss dann
relativen frieden in afghanistan an ja
auf der seite des pazifisten die sagen
hinkriegen aber jetzt müssen wir einmal
monaten war die nato noch hirntod heute
man das unter sich auf deutsche muss
auf die straße gehen dass er vor dem mut
nato hat und es wurde auch sofort
inspekteur des heeres geht nach vorne
nicht im wechsel diskutieren das ist
auf der welt garantieren durch
irgendwie gesagt menschliche sicherheit
geht ihr uns bitte aus gelbe fällt und
diesen auftrag jetzt voll umfänglich
auch wenn man es am ende gar nicht
sicherheit die gestärkt wird durch
werden angegriffen werden wenn ihr nicht
nur ein argument wenn ich der stärkere
seiner verantwortung gerecht werden den
grundsätzlich was kritisierst du an der
deutschen heeres anfangs meist er
diese diskussion so wichtig also hast du
davon reden dass putin wirklich der
schreibt den gerne in die kommentare
der grund das so zu sagen wir nicht die
grausam was da passiert und ich denke
diese person das macht vor dem müssen
schafft hat das irgendwie wäre dass man
weniger sozusagen mittel zur verfügung
angekündigt dass zwei prozent ziel vom
dass man keine waffen braucht und dass
militärische stärke oder eben doch durch
und dieser frieden dieser relative
helfen und deutschland hat nicht
greift der politik vor und sagt wir
jetzt könnt ihr euch gerne positionieren
erklärte nach der russischen invasion
ernährung landwirtschaft 1,95 milliarden
zwei prozent anteil eben leisten wie es
steht die nato so geschlossen zusammen
wird und ich finde auf diese logik des
erfüllen zu können das steht jetzt auf
ganz plump gesagt weil wir das für ihn
ist eines unserer ziele frieden und
ich war vorhin schon ein bisschen in der
es versucht ja definitiv denke ich auch
militärische strukturen
aktuellen außenpolitik oder an der wie
waffen keinen frieden schaffen ich sehe
die opposition die kümmerlichen reste
absolute inbegriff von toxischer
geholfen zunächst aber es geht ja gerade
frieden ist über die nächsten jahre
stärkeren auf diese kriegslogik sind
hat so und diesen diskussionsprozess den
besprochen hatten kein problem damit
ukraine heute sind das ist nato und der
andere lösungen meine gäste bei 310
diese menschen und dieses land die
bruttoinlandsprodukt den
sicherheit und wie kommen wir denn da
dass die bundeswehr eigentlich nur
brauchen panzer der inspekteur der
richtung unterwegs also kein kein geld
natürlich haben wir internationale
da wie lange nicht vielleicht wie noch
der ton war sehr respektvoll aber war
leider in der realität in der wir heute
sie bisher in deutschland war also
der agenda und das war mehr als
jahre lang uns an die summe von gerade
der opposition in russland unterstützen
männlichkeit ist was machen wir jetzt
verteidigungsausgaben zu stecken der
dann möchte ich mich nicht einlassen
erodiert es wurde immer kriegerischer es
darum dass das budget was die nato
deutsche aufgerüstet und in uniform zu
hin und meiner meinung nach nicht über
bedingt einsatzbereit sei und dass sie
fragen sind sich uneinig aber wir sind
brauchen unsere hilfe dringend ich
eu und wir müssen glaubwürdig sein in
in der nato auch vorgesehen ist und noch
führen wir auch im koalitionsvertrag
luftwaffe lässt sich neue kampfjets auf
und das wird glaube ich auch dass die
auch sehr lustvoll und dafür sind wir
leben keine alternative wir haben
also also wenn wir als deutschland sagen
geben angriffswaffen also ich finds
zusammenarbeit und diplomat ihren haben
nie in ihrer geschichte und diese
nato auch noch über zu erfüllen das ist
bundeswehr mit 100 milliarden plus 2%
dringend geld brauche was sagst du denn
vielleicht auch gerade in dieser debatte
steht drin diskussion einer nationalen
überfällig franziska würdest du sagen
auch mal argumentation nämlich barbara
insgesamt hat trotzdem nicht ausgereicht
ja auch hier um kompromisse zu finden
sehen gerade wegen der historischen
richtig zu sagen das muss vorher
stabilisierung des systems putin
auch hier kommt zum streiten und das
der abschreckung gegenüber der
hey wir machen eine feministische
gab immer mehr auseinandersetzung und
militärische maßnahmen sondern darüber
das betrieben aber wir haben irgendwie
autokratische regime wir haben
möchte nur
dazu glaube ich haben wir uns einfach
entschlusskraft die der kanzler in
erfüllung 167 milliarden
irgendwie geld gesprochen
den hof stellen um atomwaffen ja
dass dieses zitat was paul da gerade
deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt ob sich
eine komplette debatte vorweg genommen
außenpolitik wie geht man dann mit
sicherheitsstrategie und dem ersten jahr
hätten wir uns mit der deutschen
passieren ich bin gespannt was für
haben wir gut getan
dafür plädieren ob wir nicht
wenn dann noch ganz kurz damit wir zu
in syrien und in so vielen anderen
verantwortung liegt hat heute
beitragen das sollte unsere aufgabe
dass wir uns dass wir eben massiv
russischen föderation damit wir nicht
diktaturen die ganz klar sagen was deren
hat in afghanistan das militär
macht kriminalistische außenpolitik aus
hat um an dieser stelle abzuschrecken
die beiden seiten heute ein bisschen
rausgeholt hat in der jetzigen zeit
dennoch muss ich sagen dass ich alles
konflikten gesehen wie sich aggressoren
bundeswehr in einem ähnlichen szenario
eurem kompromissvorschlag kommen können
leuten wie putin um das ist genau der
zuverlässiger transportieren zu können
seiner regierungserklärung zum ausdruck
nach regierungsantritt wird ein papier
historisch bedingt aus der verantwortung
aufgerüstet und die streitkräfte
intelligentere lösungen finden als jetzt
investieren in entwicklungen
wobei noch gar nicht entschieden ist was
es ist zu wenig wie viel würdest du denn
aufeinander zu bewegen werden und ob sie
deutschland diese verantwortung aktiv an
bis zu dem punkt an dem ihr gesagt habt
angegriffen werden was hat ihnen gedacht
jetzt heute so noch funktioniert und
punkt warum ich sagt man muss zusammen
dass hier eben sicherheit
was entgegnet zu diesem konkreten
mission ist und was deren motivation ist
gebracht hat das ist die führung die wir
wie in der ukraine gerade hätten wir uns
schon sehr emotionalisiert weil ich find
sagen
gezogen und gesagt historisch können wir
dastehen mit genau diesen fragen die
präventionen menschenrechtsschutz et
niemand denkt auch die anderen
wird was beschafft wird aus diesen 100
ausgestattet und letztendlich gelangte
deutschland aufzurüsten du hast ja
verhalten und wir haben darauf nicht
denken also man muss auf der einen seite
ausgeben für europäische sicherheit und
100% 100 prozent ich glaube das ist ganz
sich vielleicht sogar auf eine
es schwer über diese teams sprechen ohne
ausgehend von menschliche sicherheit
noch anwendbar ist
als wir gehört haben dass wir in der
abschreckung hätte schon passiert sein
argumente ich würde sagen dass also
diesem internationalen
da verteidigen können was der inspekteur
einfach nicht deutsche wieder in uniform
cetera also das ist hier jetzt mal ein
die ist leider sehr sehr fern von
möglichkeiten mit mit denen sich
sagen wir bekennen uns zur
viel weiter sind als nur auf den engen
reagiert mit einer massiven stärkung von
milliarden und wir haben seit jahren die
gemeinsame friedenspolitik einigen
dadurch emotionalisiert zu werden weil
jetzt brauchen in dieser situation
frieden das ist eine absolute frank
zukunft sehr stark in die bundeswehr
kunstdruck teilzunehmen und wir können
nein würde ich auf keinen fall sagen
müssen hätte ich auch zum stück aber das
denkt und dass das was im fokus steht
erstens ist die ukraine nicht alle nato
des heeres gemacht hat ist eine
feministischen aussenpolitik und wir
man an den punkt dass all das nicht
selbst einen appell gegen eine massive
deutschland jetzt schützen könnte wir
ordentliches hingegen kaum vom bau oder
unserer und deshalb können wir nur mit
haben und starkes militär und ich sehe
ich tatsächlich an die leute denken
frage und die gelder werden seit 2014
wichtig dass wir die russische
ich höre gerade führung ich höre stärke
umfang der der bundeswehr also geht es
können deswegen die erste frage an euch
diskussion dass deutschland das zwei
deshalb hat die ukraine deshalb die nato
defizitanalyse in sehr drastischen
hochrüstung der bundeswehr
unterfüttern die auch im
geholfen hat ich habe nicht gesehen dass
weil genau wie stefan richtig gesagt hat
könnte ich erkenne und ich denke aber
zivile krisenprävention beispielsweise
investieren wollen schreibt mal in die
würde ich sagen ihr seid doch alle einen
es gerade ich sehe gerade das gegenteil
einfach nicht in deutschland uns
stärke und mit abschreckung entgegnen
ist ja dass das ist irgendwie die kerne
brauchen dringend
eben nicht ist dass es
prozent ziel der nato erfüllen soll und
außenministerium zum beispiel wie
unterschrieben wie hast du denn
das ist alles was heute hier gefallen
schritt auf sie zugegangen absolut und
zivilgesellschaft
wo auf dem feld würdet ihr stehen grün
zurücklehnen und sagen wenn in syrien
worten die hat er hingelegt der politik
mir einfach eine andere
gab es überhaupt eine parlamentarische
permanent erhöht offensichtlich hat die
kommentare barbara kann es verstehen
ja immer wieder versucht klarzustellen
auch um die punkte die orale
fähigkeiten um auf geflüchtete zu
ich glaube es ist in deutschlands
diese aufrüstung dazu geführt hat dass
priorisieren die als bundesregierung
auf der gegenseite wurden drei schritte
sicherheitspolitische situation jetzt
also wir haben da ein ganz viel auf ganz
das ganz gut tatsächlich widerspiegelt
persönlich diesen richtungswechsel der
ich kann das auch nur unterstreichen
ursache von konflikten ar nic und ich
angesprochen hast die werden da alle
das dass es um staatliche sicherheit
ich meine scholz war extra in russland
und die ist nach meiner bewertung
verantwortung dass das
das tut deutschland jetzt als reaktion
chemische waffen eingesetzt werden dann
dass die 53 milliarden nicht ausgereicht
aber auf der anderen seite sind eben
haben wir haben ja immer versucht
reagieren wir brauchen dringend
abgebildet in diesem dokument aber es
was im landkreis los ist weil wir im
vor allem die gerade auf die straße
es friedlich einem land geworden ist und
viele mittel die uns zur verfügung
politik wahrgenommen also
fähigkeiten um auf chemische atomare und
diesen krieg jetzt zu verhindern wo
die kommentare dann gilt für euch ab
auf den krieg das hätte völlig
sicherheit muss vernetzt gedacht werden
nach hinten gegangen paul was sagst du
geht die verteidigt wird mit
stehen würden nicht zugegriffen so viele
diplomatie frieden herzustellen und mit
können wir da auch nicht interesse
auch bereit wenn wir uns gegnern
grunde eigentlich glaube ich überfordert
zutreffend deswegen würde ich auch nicht
glaube nicht dass abschreckung
das nicht mal große teile der spd
haben zur abschreckung ja ich finde das
hat gesagt das thema ukrainischer
das ist für mich etwas was ich vor ort
gehen obwohl sie wissen dass sie dadurch
geht ja genauso um die investitionen
bild so zu prägen und die internationale
ausgereicht aber jetzt diese 100
sind ein bisschen mit dieser großen
können wir nicht eingreifen weil es ist
militärischen strukturen und das dass
jetzt wenn wir der anderen seite in
ich glaube ich möchte darauf dass sich
beitritt zur nato steht nicht auf der
gegenüber sehen wie zb pushen die damit
friedensstiftend wirkt okay dann finde
sollen wir noch mehr erhöhen und wir
ressort übergreifend ressort gemeinsam
wirklich eingeweiht waren diesen
beispielsweise eben in haushalte für das
von aufrüstung sprechen sondern von
in den knast kommen dass das wirklich
skript quasi an so ein bisschen an die
gesprächen den frieden zu sichern genau
menschenrechtsorganisationen haben
zu nellys argument dass die rosarote
das wichtigste ist und dass danach die
einem argument zustimmen wollt dann
sehr persönlich erfahren habe und
so weit weg und es ist eigentlich ganz
tagesordnung ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
biologische angriffe und
milliarden in den raum zu stellen das
entscheidung ich glaube das ist auch
haben doch die situation dass auch im
wahnsinn dass ich absolut mein hut auf
entschluss also ich hab das gefühl haben
antworten mit nicht nur in worten
und nicht nur im engen feld der sie also
weltordnung irgendwie auch so mit zu
bekleben ich glaube dass deswegen
einer sachgerechten ausrüstung der
einfach gar nichts am hut haben und das
das problem ist eigentlich dass die
beispielsweise auch so lange schon
könnt ihr das gerne mit einer bewegung
anderen dinge kommen sondern dass das
okay überfordert zu sein also ich finde
letzten jahr und in den jahren davor
sondern mit diesen worten hier
wie olaf scholz ist damit beschrieben
sorgt dafür dass in den nächsten jahren
herausforderungen zu reagieren aber was
sie mit einer hinterzimmer politik zu
weswegen ich sage nein aufrüstung kann
ursprüngliche frage von vorhin
deutschen auch wirklich eine ganz aktive
ich gespannt auf euer
ministerium etwas auswärtige amt und die
und einfach weiter waffen in waffen
brille aufhat es ist nicht so dass das
prägen und zu gestalten als westlich
verdeutlichen und einen schritt nach
bundeswehr die groß verbände der
die anderen seite müssen wir anerkennen
gegner immer wieder sagen naja aber am
gewarnt vor einer weiteren eskalation
hat nicht durch aufrüstung sondern durch
kompromissvorschlag dazu führt dass die
tun
dass die
das ja schon recht als am anfang gesagt
besorgen wir in erster linie wollen wir
und jahrzehnten menschen oder andere
teile des bundeswehr geht es überhaupt
tatsächlich frieden kann heute und in
der der der harten militärischen
irgendwie wissen ist dass wir jetzt
nicht das ziel sein wir sind überhaupt
vorne gehen und wenn ihr etwas richtig
rolle international nehmen muss paul du
haushalte sind kleine angesetzt als in
ich habe jetzt einen schritt zurück hat
eben menschliche sicherheit also
andere seite zumindest auf euch zu geht
der situation und man kann jetzt nicht
was eigentlich quasi diese zeitenwende
liberalen demokratie daniel du bist
zustimmungsraten zu putin seit
plötzlich mit dem aufwachen noch dass
gespräche und wir sehen jetzt in der
sicherheit und ganz ganz unterstützen
investieren die eben einen krieg
landstreitkräfte sind nicht voll
blöd was die andere seite sagt und das
mehr panzer in erster linie wollen wir
hat wir brauchen darüber eine debatte ja
nicht abgerufen worden sind weil die
den jahren davor also ich verstehe die
länder auf uns zukommen werden und das
nicht in der lage auf das zu reagieren
ich glaube die sp war eingeweiht aber
ernährung
bist freundlichen schritt nach hinten
unser kompromissvorschlag ist dass
kriegsbeginn gestiegen sind auf bis zu
dieser welt nicht mehr militärisch
beginnen dass wir gleichzeitig bereit
ukraine aktuell was passiert wenn der
wir ad hoc reagieren müssen 2014 aktion
ausmacht weil sich ja schon die frage
denjenigen sagen dass wir eine rosarote
nicht zurückgegangen wir haben uns als
was jetzt dieser krieg da in russland
mit euren ganzen körper zum ausdruck
ausgerüstet das heißt die soldatinnen
gegangen ich glaube einfach ganz
zugang zu bildung wirtschaftliche
ist genau das das problem es geht uns ja
dann auch einfordern werden ich habe
hergestellt werden sicherheit und
ich frage mich gab es sozusagen eine
ich finde das könnte irgendwo auch dann
logik hinter dem
bundeswehr gar nicht in der lage war
mehr kampfflugzeuge und wollen eine de
sind darauf zu reagieren um nichts
gesprächspartner sich nicht ehrlich
70 prozent und deshalb finde ich ehrlich
investitionen in sicherheit zu
grundlegend es gibt intelligentere wege
eben insgesamt vier auslandseinsätzen
das ist sozusagen auf meinem eine
gerade ausgelöst hat und wir werden
der krim wir hatten massive russische
diesen etat denen sie jetzt schon hat
anderes geht es ja
sonderposten oder die argumentation ich
gestellt was für eine aufgabe hat die
deutschland nicht aus der verantwortung
parlamentarische und wirklich eine
bringen wollt dann macht das gerne indem
gar nicht darum die nato irgendwie auch
macht und zwar gespräche führt am tisch
brille auf hatten wenn wir diese
kein teil dazu beitragen dass man zum
und soldaten die jetzt im an der
facto atommacht sein weil wir quasi
frieden sind nur politisch herstellbar
gesagt da sind wir wie beim thema
ressourcen aber eben auch also dass das
auch wenn ich mich wiederhole tut mir
paul sachs udo
öffentliche debatte über das ist er
genommen wir haben bei gestanden als die
immer und zuerst in menschliche
ihr einen schritt nach hinten kind ich
bundeswehr was soll die bundeswehr
der bundeswehr die wirkung von waffen in
erfahrung
rosarote brille umgesetzt haben
zu bleiben oder so es geht darum auf
sinnvoll zu verwenden da wurden dann
rosarote brille und jetzt fragen uns
ostflanke des bündnisgebietes in den
definitiv mit mehr waffen es auch nicht
beispiel in den kommentaren oder so
beschlossen wurde ich denke so ein
sitzt auch die gespräche mit macht aber
die bundeswehr heute ist nicht die
leid als selber auf die logik des
erfüllen und was wollen wir sozusagen
eine aktuelle andere sicherheitslage zu
bin mir aber nicht sicher ob
diese faktoren eben genauso relevant
stellvertreter bei der auslieferung von
sozusagen ich glaube wichtig ist
deshalb setzen wir uns für eine
großer schritt der unser land massiv
diskutiert und auch nach dieser
also die sache kann ja nicht sein dass
sicherheit
wünsche uns jetzt erstmal eine schöne
rüstungsprojekte nicht zeitgerecht
mit dem budget erfüllen und all diese
krieges einzusteigen und ich finde halt
okay es gibt gerade krieg was machen wir
usa angegriffen worden sind auch beim
das verlässlich ist wenn brasilien der
kriegs- und krisengebiete erlebt und
einsatz gehen um die alliierten wird zu
erreichen dass wir da wieder zu mehr
getätigt werden müssen und dass wenn die
diskussion paul ich fange mit dir an du
sind wir noch so sicherheitsrelevant
anzuerkennen dass uns abschreckung und
atomraketen sind für die usa da würde
eine andere zukunft führt die sicherlich
wir quasi auf toxische männlichkeit mit
reagieren mehr live diskutieren ja die
und dann sagst du ja gut okay wir müssen
fertig
sicherheitspartnerschaft die auch den
diskussion jetzt das als startpunkt für
dass wir die ganze zeit auch in
dann am ende eine kriegerische
nationale volksarmee wir dienen keiner
fragen sind halt auch noch nicht
sind und das andere ist und deswegen
gesehen das hat mich zum pazifisten
jetzigen haushaltsdebatte schon ein
irgendwie militärische dominanz
ganze zeit hier wie auf seiner basis von
das geld konnte einfach nicht richtig
frieden beitragen stefan kannst du
irak krieg auch wenn nach vorne hin
aufrüstung auch in der vergangenheit
ich gerne anknüpfen und gehe über indie
hast 2016 mit deiner band in kiew
jetzt die opposition die so und so viel
reagieren also im sinne also der
sichern gegen die bedrohung von russland
gegnern der gegenwärtigen militärblöcke
auseinandersetzung ein krieg beginnt in
eine weitere debatte irgendwie
meine generation die generation danach
investitionen in bundeswehr oder
komischen kategorien in komischen
sozusagen dieser feministischer aspekt
partei wir dienen auch keinem
gemacht krieg darf immer nur das
diesen punkt von daniel nachvollziehen
dass wir diese situation jetzt gerade
anderer eindruck entsteht und
genutzt werden also man muss vielleicht
nicht mehr sicherheit gebracht hat
noch viel mehr ausbauen müssen als die
betreuende denkt okay das klingt so als
unser kanzler gesagt hat nein zum
kompromiss rundes läuft jetzt wie folgt
umfänglich beantwortet oder diskutiert
partner bei der schaffung von sicherheit
gespielt zwei jahre vorher hatte
prozent der positionen stärken müssen
europa und darauf kann man nicht mit
kerngedanke für minister außenpolitik
müssen sich aus den gesamten
dass es darum geht dass nicht alle
würdest du deinen schritt auf ihn
gleichzeitig müssen wir einfach über
militärische strukturen getätigt werden
als zäsur empfinden annalena baerbock
entgegengesetzten kategorien denken
allerletzte mittel sein pazifismus
noch mal sozusagen erklärend zu den 100
stattdessen sollten wir auf das setzen
zugehen die punkte die zu afghanistan
ich habe ein kompromiss von mir an euch
stehen das was diskutiert werden es kann
streitkräften ihre ausrüstung ihr
und das heißt eigentlich brauchen wir
russland bereits die krim annektiert
wir keine frage aber das wird eben den
irakkrieg nach hinten hin haben unsere
durch immer mehr abrüstung und
ist ja wirklich
menschen
würdet ihr euch jetzt erstmal für diese
menschen die möglichkeiten zu gleicher
abrissen reagieren sondern mit
diese trennung oder wir müssen
hat von einer anderen welt gesprochen in
haben einerseits verteidigung sicherheit
dafür bevor wir substanziell investieren
material zusammen suchen und wir müssen
krieg jetzt nicht beenden und deshalb
außenpolitik anders zu denken und
dass nur stattfindet im sinne von den
bedeutet dass wir weiterhin nach einer
was beispiel die regierung auch im
erzähl mal wie hast du die gespräche wie
mal gucken wir den findet das könnten
aufrüstung ich bin der meinung dass wir
gesagt worden kann ich nachvollziehen
politische entspannung macht das sind
eigentlich darüber hinwegkommen zu sagen
geheimdienste unterstützt all das ist
milliarden sagen dass das zwei prozent
teilhabe zugleich gestaltung macht und
sage ich da müssen wir jetzt eben drauf
menschheits verbrecher wie adolf hitler
nicht einfach mal eben so an einem
13 fragen folge nicht viel weiter
ich erkenne an dass sicherheit ein
natürlich ist die frage wie gehen wir
der wir nach dem angriff in der ukraine
hast du die leute vor ort wahrgenommen
das eine sind ausgaben in sicherheit
in die lage kommen dass jeder soldat in
wir gleich erzählen wenn ihr wollt könnt
sonntag wer draußen in berlin eine
weil ich auch dann kann es einen schritt
mittlerweile auch sehr deutlich
friedlichen lösung suchen die politik
ziehen und die 100 milliarden
aufeinander zubewegen ich glaube das ist
in die wehrmacht gedient hat bedienen
reagieren und wenn putin offensichtlich
grundlegendes bedürfnis wissen wir alles
defensiven denken im sinne von keine
und würdest du sagen dass die menschen
zum einen theoretischen debatte wofür
nicht meine worte sind die worte von
gegenseitig angerechnet werden das heißt
riesige anti kriegs demo über straßen
ressourcen haben und dass politik
ihr dann einen schritt auf mich zugehen
aufgewacht sind und der wir jetzt leben
damit wir sozusagen unsere
auf ihn zu gehen ich sage auch gleich
nachvollziehbar da war ein deutscher
mit aggressoren wie putin und natürlich
der freiheit der demokratie und dem
aber auch komplett okay weil diese
olaf scholz und dann jetzt dem
gibt diese bedürfnispyramide von maslow
leider sehr früh aufgibt sobald sie sich
oder zurück oder stehenbleiben und dann
nicht bereit ist auf diplomatie zu
die 100 milliarden werden in der
jeder brigade in jeder division der
warum ich den schritt nicht machen kann
mit denen du dort gesprochen hast dass
lebensgrundlagen sichern können und dann
angriffswaffen im sinne von in einer
eigentlich plus es gibt massive kritik
deswegen das hauptziel haben muss eben
hat sie denn deiner meinung nach recht
ist dann die frage wir sind konfrontiert
geheimdienst dabei beteiligt diese
läuft beschließen franziska du bist ein
bundeskanzler
recht heute die soldatinnen soldaten
zerrissenheit also ihr seid euch ja
reagieren müssen wir deshalb eben unsere
die schule mit dieser eskalation und
dass sicherheit ein großer ein großes
weil ich auch zweimal in afghanistan war
könnt ihr jeweils auf eurem fällt also
kommen können wir uns um alles andere
landstreitkräfte über das material
für den krieg bereit erklärt was sagst
mit irgendwie sehr
1987 als er noch bei den jusos war und
kriegsgründe mit zu konstruieren also
also hat dieser krieg und dieser angriff
jetzigen legislaturperiode dazu genutzt
immer und immer mal wieder ein bisschen
auch mit diesem krieg so gerechnet haben
das zu ändern weil leben eben diesen
schritt nach hinten gegangen stimmt so
kümmern weil das zum beispiel auch
sind schon sehr reflektierte
verteilungs fähigkeit leider in die
thema aber auf der anderen seite tun wir
kann ich sie nachvollziehen und habe
verfügt was er für diesen auftrag
an den beschaffungs strukturen massiv
aufeinander zugegangen ich glaube dies
ihr einmal auf dem grünfeld ja immer auf
paul nicht zu denn ich glaube dass es
du dazu den punkt denn deine gerade
strukturellen ungleichheiten eben
unsere welt so fundamental verändert ich
harten realitäten und irgendwie in dem
partie als mittel ausgespielt das haben
ähnliche persönliche erfahrungen kundus
so als wäre investitionen die nicht in
haben wir auch da eine verantwortung die
also wir 2016 da gespielt in kiew
staatsbürger in uniform und darum bin
einhergeht mit den herausforderungen die
braucht und das ist zurzeit nicht
kritik an der effizienz die dahinter
dem gelben fällt die köpfe
auf einer friedenskundgebung sich so
spiegelt auch den gesellschaftlichen
angeführt das kannst du diese
wahnsinnig viel konfliktpotenzial liegt
jährlich einen etat zu haben der
total wichtig ist da würde ich jetzt
wir alle diplomatischen mittel aus
wir haben wie zum beispiel klimawandel
zusammenstecken und euch einen
die bundesregierung eine unglaubliche
überrumpelung sage ich jetzt mal so
stand dazu ganz gut wieder deswegen
sichergestellt ok also ganz kurze
und faisabad gemacht ich kann deswegen
steht und die frage ist zum einen hilft
ich auch heute hier um das sozusagen mal
et cetera und dafür müssen wir
wir wenn auch eine fragwürdige aber im
einen kleinen schritt auf dich zugehen
gerettet wisst ihr mehr weil ihr seid
positioniert hat und warum hast du genau
komme ungern auf die rosarote brille
passivität und diese diese diese diese
franziska nelly ihr seid ja ein schritt
kompromissvorschlag für die andere seite
startet er halt aggressiv einem
salopp ganz grundsätzlich verstehen also
ungefähr bei zwei prozent liegt und das
verständnisfragen die konsequenz daraus
bedanke ich mich vielmals bei euch für
meine politik ich bin einfach nur
das sind halb dass wir da drin und
deutsch japanische freundschaft zwar ein
zurück ich glaube wir sind in derselben
in dieser großen öffentlichkeit auch zu
auf barbara zugegangen wie so weil ich
überlegen auf basis der diskussion die
eigentlich auch investieren und
keinen schritt auf ihn zu machen weil
musiker ich habe davon kann ein solches
dieses zitat von ihm ausgesucht weil ich
völkerrechtswidrigen krieg führt ja aber
dann mehr geld wenn wir sowieso schon
diese diskussion ich glaube die
ist wir brauchen mehr geld meiner
welt aufgewacht es ist einfach nur in
dieser dogmatismus quellen gar nicht es
rahmen dieses bündnis mit zu tragen
toller abend deutsche botschaft hat
ich glaub mein riesen
ist deswegen so wichtig dass irgendwie
glaube schon dass es wichtig ist gerade
war wenige tage vor kriegsbeginn bei
wir jetzt geführt haben deswegen kommt
kommunikationsproblem buyvip von
natürlich stellt sich die frage wofür
es zu 100 prozent schreiben möchte wie
sagen und dokumentieren und beileibe
organisiert eine wand aus kiew und wir
die situation russland ukraine eine
haben barbara paul war deutschland
das ist ja also darauf zu reagieren im
bürger mitnehmen und das ist eine
meinung nach wir brauchen mehr geld um
deutschland plötzlich unbequem geworden
putin hat sich mit ihm an diesem ihren
das geld da und wofür nicht er geht
aufrüstung sprechen aber es geht ja um
wenn man zum beispiel wissenschaftliche
die mittelfristige finanzplanung
eine sachgerechte ausrüstung vorzunehmen
jetzt erst mal ein kompromissvorschlag
keine sozusagen
reagiert 8-liter schritt geht alle einen
sinne von wir brauchen quasi deswegen
parlamentarische debatte gibt das ist
haben da gespielt und im anschluss an
aufgrund der geschichte zu ängstlich
langen crazy tisch gesetzt und hat
studien die es dazu gibt es jetzt seit
weil ja kriege auch weltweit in anderen
an euch können wir uns darauf einigen
andere ist als syrien und afghanistan
sicherheit bietet für rüstungsprojekte
die verteidigung auch um die
eine militärische grundausrüstung um uns
ganz ganz wichtig so wird es ja geben
dass es in den letzten jahren nicht
das konzert was eigentlich gar nicht so
neuestem viel dazu die minister
gesagt wir werden die ukraine der der
verteidigung der westlichen liberalen
dass wir höhere investitionen in die
schritt nach hinten stefan warum bis zum
davor wieder mehr deutsche in uniformen
richtig geschenkt da ist dann hat er
wir haben hier ist nicht mit terroristen
ländern geführt werden und wir uns der
aufregend war aber so geladene gäste
außenpolitik dann sieht man dass zum
dann um die anderen sachen kümmern zu
für die beschaffung von
schritt nach hinten gegangen bei diesem
werte einer demokratie die wir in
sicherheit machen müssen aber diese
beitritt der ukraine zur nato ist
gerne ein hat dadurch einen haken ja ich
rüstungsprojekten die eben deutlich
können das ist ja quasi das problem das
waren waren wir so einer kleinen kneipe
ganz bequem zurücklehnen und das die
beispiel an friedensverhandlungen an den
zu tun sondern mit strategischen
zitat was toll rausgeholt hat weil ich
und weil er eigentlich interessante teil
komplexer sind als die beschaffung
absolut nicht auf dem tisch berbalk war
deutschland sicherstellen müssen weil
anderen machen lassen und was ich auch
habe als auf der fahrt hin gefahren bin
nicht auf militärische ausgaben
streitkräften der russischen föderation
frauen teilnehmen dass der frieden
wir auch in deutsch und uns vor einem
irgendwie einer neuen küche zu hause die
glaube dass der 24 februar
in russland und die sagen alle alle
beschränken das wäre mein
länger hält beispielsweise also ich
und der gegner ist ein anderer deswegen
ballistischen angriff schützen müssen in
glaube das thema teilhabe zum beispiel
wesentlich schwieriger sind in der
2022 eine neue ära darstellt dass der 24
kompromissvorschlag an euch ihr könnt
ist auch der konflikt ein anderer und
ist ein sehr wichtiges und wenn wir das
wenn ihr wollt ein schritt auf mich
planung und dann sozusagen in der in der
ist weil russland nuklearmacht ist
zugehen können auch ein schritt zurück
umsetzung und deswegen ist die
mittelfristige finanzplanung so wichtig
also 100 milliarden gibt es das ist
richtig aber die werden auf das zwei
prozent ziel angerechnet wenn ich das
richtig verstehe wäre das
verteidigungsministerium dass man
soziale danach das zweite stärkste
ministerium ministerium der finanzen ist
doch irgendwie also ich glaube einfach
dass jeder euro den wir in bildung den
wir in kultur den wir
städtepartnerschaften investieren für
den frieden langfristig besser angelegt
als jetzt mehr waffen zu kaufen fragt
doch mal deine freundin der ukraine was
ihr freund ob sie jetzt das geld in die
schulen investieren würden oder um ihre
verteidigung in ihrer verteidigung
investiert in eine vermischung von außen
blüten in politischen fragen konnten
aber das duo ideen durch die ministerien
seitig aufgerechnet hast das verstehe
ich jetzt nicht ja aber wenn leute wie
ich und leute draußen ist angucken die
können sich gar nicht vorstellen was
eine milliarde ist die können sich noch
weniger forschung was 100 milliarden
sind dessen habe ich die anderen zahlen
oft wird immer sieht inwiefern sozial
die relation ist zudem was dann auf dem
tisch liegt und wir leute ich noch
jünger sind als ich die hören die ganze
zeit joachim klimawandel haben wir echt
nicht so viel dass man echt schwer das
mit bevölkerung wirklich auf sehr hohe
investitionen vorbereiten da wird alles
irgendwie sehr vorsichtig angefasst
jetzt plötzlich tauchen von irgendwoher
diese hundert milliarden euro auf ich
knüpfe an deutschland hat mit knapp 53
milliarden dollar 2020 den siebtgrößten
verteidigungshaushalt weltweit zum
vergleich russland weil du vergleichst
foul russland gab 1 9 milliarden dollar
für das militär aus also russland 9
milliarden die 53 milliarden dollar
wogegen denn das ganze geld in der
vergangenheit hin stefan also hat das
nicht gereicht ganz doof naiv gefragt
irgendwie muss man es ja verstehen
können also in den letzten
jahren muss sagen jahrzehnten
hatten wir das was wir friedensdividende
nennen das heißt wir hatten deutlich
höhere verteidigungsausgaben vor 1990
und wir hatten auch deutlich ältere
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]